assalamualaikum we're gonna go find out
right now in this month there's someone
who's about to accept Islam why they
about their scepter somehow they gonna
do it let's go find now Diego how you
doing come on up you want more than two
million dollars billion and we talked a
little bit about why you accepted Islam
we went over the six articles of faith
pretty easy to understand huh
then we went over the five pillars of
Islam what'd you think about that
beautifully so anything you want to
share with us with all of the mass
manipulation all of the media hype you
transcended all that and you're here
with us tell us about your experience in
it what drew you to Islam I think I've
been searching for purpose and I've
always been a very friendly you know
driven person but I was kind of blinded
on many to care about one another and
that they lost importance of that I
really is truly why we're here what we
should do is care for each other and
love each other I think is
I think it's Prince of Peace love
acceptance and I do want to learn a lot
more still so now you know we went over
the five pillars and the start of it
starts with the declaration there's over
a whole world of things to learn but you
take in the first step that first step
is to give birth to what's already
inside to testify that there is nothing
worthy of worship except the crater that
has an earth Allah no deity worthy of
worship except Allah and Muhammad is the
seal of the prophets
the final Messenger of God so I'm going
to go ahead and say it in English and
then you repeat after me and then we'll
do it in every house that I bear witness
that there's no deity worthy of worship
except Allah and I bear witness that
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
is the final messenger of allah and i
bear witness that Jesus the Son of Mary
is the safe slave servant and messenger
of allah servant and messenger messenger
you ready now and lad Allah Allah and
now Muhammad assumable
takbir alright so now it's very
important is there anybody here
one guardian angel somebody to connect
with the brother I'm gonna give you one
recommendation it's called new Muslim
academy.com so that's one reference one
place to start for new Muslims very
important we talked about seeking
knowledge right getting the tools you
need for light Aslam gives you all of
that so we got one who's a volunteer
that go ahead and teach you know fati
how can you imagine the rewards now one
person stepping up to connect with some
exchange number you're there brother
okay you got a family of what close to
two billion one is that we're not to
help you right with some of the basics
welcome to Islam
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
his wife also she's a Muslim and they
did their nikka here mashallah so below
so he accepted Islam yeah and did right
away then got married how long since I
got me know since you accept Islam a
year August yeah so how's it been I know
I really good what was it what was it
about it's not the head you accept yes
um I would say someone I spoke to about
Islam she kind of presented like that
but it says I didn't really have
anything to say about Islam because I
didn't really know anything about it
prior to miss speaking to like she told
me basically about like you know how the
Bible was rewritten and stuff like that
people of course call the gospel books
Matthew Mark Luke and John well they
call the Matthew Mark Luke and John
because we don't know who wrote these
books and there's no point calling them
Sam Fred Jerry and Harry I mean they're
they're written by people we don't know
who they were written by they are
anonymous you might not think so because
they have the title the Gospel according
to Matthew whoever put that title on it
was an editor later the followers of
Jesus were Aramaic speaking peasants
from Galilee lower-class men who were
not educated in fact Peter and John in
Acts chapter 4 verse 13 are literally
said to be illiterate they couldn't read
and write of course not they were
fishermen they didn't go to school the
vast majority of people in the ancient
world never learned to read let alone
write and their native language was
Aramaic these books are written in Greek
by highly educated rhetorically trained
writers who are skilled in Greek
composition and you know at the time I
you know I never really wasn't that in
general a devoted Christian so as soon
as she like presented these evidences
that I never
ever in my life you know I begin to like
think about you just look you know just
do my own research it wasn't like you
know I was thinking like well when it
came become a Muslim or anything it was
just like you know okay this is
interesting you know where did she get
all this why does she say peace be upon
him she mentions the Prophet and you
know I was wondering all these things so
I just begin to do my research and then
I came across a video on YouTube and
about this brother who took a Shahada
and then like the ship or the Imam was
kind of talking to him and telling him
about his name and he was he like
started to cry you know I was like man
why why is he crying you know so I like
I like looked up mosque near me and I
just came to the mosque and at the time
you know I had my girlfriend who's my
wife now and a lot and she moved in with
me and you know I became Muslim and then
I just started give her Dawa and I told
a mom at the mosque about the situation
about how you know I want to be with her
but I understand you know I'm Muslim now
I you know that's not permissible to be
in like on marital relationship yeah so
I brought her to the mosque
she saw the way we prayed and everything
and hummed Allah she was like oh I want
to take much harder so the same day on
the lot he took our Nicholas to say
there's a three-shot oh yeah what would
have been like some of the challenges
and how did you get over them some of
the challenges that I faced I would say
kind of learning everything and kind of
just like trying to figure things out
but also keeping in mind that you have
to follow the Sunnah and the Quran so
you can't just go off your nafs and your
desires you know hon doula so you know I
just started speaking to like one of the
Imams here and he kind of helped me a
lot
um he teach he send me like videos about
how you know the prophets prayer
described you know may Allah raise his
ranking and grant him peace
yes oh yeah what what advice now would
you give I mean now it's like you know
just taking this jihad that you you
accept this on a year ago you're coming
along we talked about importance is
following the Koran listen very
important seeking knowledge you know
you've grown what advice do you have for
Diego I would say just be patient and
also you know don't over overwhelm
yourself and definitely try to practice
learning your salat because that's very
important because I feel like if you
pray well there's evidences about it but
I can't you know I don't know I can't
remember I like at the moment I don't I
haven't memorized them but it's you know
it's very important that you do your
salat my law will guide you and show it
establish the prayer so we did the front
we just did that remember we talked
about there's five pillars in Islam so
you just established now the first one
now we move on to the second alright so
learn how to pray
you know Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings upon us you know Allah made it
easy for us until you end up learning
all the things that are needed the
requirements you can an actuality and
all the different prostrations you can
say subhanAllah and humbly not Allah -
until you learn them Fatih how the
opening chapter and the other
requirements because in each different
posture there's something now that needs
to be said but now you're just starting
to pray so you can substitute that until
you end up learning all the other things
but as long as you're praying follow me
that's that's the main thing because now
you're connected you're plugged in
without the prayer you're unplugged yeah
you follow me you're connected yeah with
with the Creator and no middle person
just you straight dial-up - anytime were
just both I'm being office or someone
old in office so we are welcome anytime
questions issues so I would try to know
how do you ensure all of us